I thought we should end the interview
right we only have a few minutes left
I'm going to bring out some wine okay
this is a little thing we like to call
the wine down who's most likely to pull
a prank Jimmy Jimmy why what kind of
pranks he's always pranking you got him
well we all got him good time because
Karen was when Karen was pregnant with
their son and real prank yeah her in the
studio and Jimmy loved to give this baby
I was like I gave it all so we I said
come on girls we can pretend and pretend
like your water broke
Jimmy was in the back we're in the
studio together and we like took a water
bottle on the floor and when he came
around that it from the bathroom
we were like Jimmy she was standing
water there's water all over and then
they all got to watch it hard to get I
love it those are the best one yeah
Kimberly who's the messiest on the tour
bus well Philip because he spills a lot
Garrett who's the biggest crier Phillip
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this